et oui oui non mais là c'est quand même
depuis 21h cinq qu'ils ont jouées quatre
coups chacun ils ont réfléchi nordiste
chacun comme bons tours d2 daniel
parcours le cookie qui est bizarre mais
qui m a l'air de marcher crac crac dic
alors stéphane est ce que c'était un bon
choix au mauvais choix cette ouverture
ce qu'on peut rappeler quand même pour
ceux qui prendra la partie en cours de
route chronique a surpris au début il a
joué fou c'est ça qui a joué d'espagnol
normale à dracy fou s'est vite il
devrait pousser 8
foncez vite il a joué pour venir comme
aura donc plus tard cette discussion
ouais bon sens le verra en résultat de
la partie il a l'air serein quand même
un pouce et huit mois je sais pas qui tu
aimes dernier coup d'oeil à la position
tous ces huit donc ils analysent
kasparov a poussé ses pions rami peut
pas 6000 serait super 4 des poussées 3
va montrer tient à yop sursis kasparov
joue maintenant b4 et bien tout
simplement fou c3 et la tour ne peut
plus protéger les 4 la tour est attaqué
et le pion b4 va tomber à noter qu'à ce
que les récupérer l'option h5 à oui mais
ça c'est pas très grave puisque une fois
qu'on applique et celui là avait lot
tout va tomber aussi nié oui mais de
toute façon il ya plus de dangers de ce
côté là donc on peut ramener droit font
de l'autre côté et tenir c'est dire que
là le problème
effectivement comme tu le prennes pour
les noirs c'est qu'il ya du danger des
deux côtés c'est ce qui pose de bonnes
puisqu'on sait pas trop où web les
droits c'est pourtant la grosse entrée
derrière le palais d'aiete mais ici si
on élimine ceux qui ont des cas c'est
facile le tranquille quatre ans ne
jouera pas des cas précis il faut
rappeler que les blancs en deux tomes
plus quand même donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils peuvent espérer encore jouer un
peu pour le gain même si en plus ça
serait pas suffisant
un peu ça ça peut être un avantage noir
puisque rappelons quand même permis qu'à
deux fous contre une tour stéphane oui
tous ses efforts
alors là qu'est ce qu'il va jouer car il
vous évite salaires précis c'est à dire
très précis de la part de chronique avec
khalid et l'idée c'est de mettre le foin
aussi simple que ça on l'avait dit enfin
dans la vidéo coup d'avant avant qu'ils
jouent faux 5
ouais on avait parlé de ce qu'on fout
c'est vite par exemple si tu y as part
of the tour à domicile sans visage
eh bien on met le fond on redessine
c'est loin trois des six maintenant
ah oui mais moi je n'hésite pas à mener
l'euro à l'attack un salaire bien ça a
l'air encore plus forte puisque on s'en
fout du progiciel comme la limite
après faut six mois ces cinq autres
idées aussi
attention je ne sais pas peut-être
possible 6,14 quitte cette colonne des
il risque de se prendre un roi des six
mois des six c'est ce plan là ça c'est
plus lui aussi envisagé est simple
stéphane un ami tout gagner car un
chronique f5 c'est pas mal mais heureux
est ce que c'est c'est obligé de prendre
tous gagnés oui mais là aussi
ah oui là aussi on prend des fous ah oui
maintenant avec le fou sur laquelle j'ai
6 ans il est passé de gymnaste
d'alliance c2i d'un salon chez 2 et le
roi de chroniques maintenant est libre
d'avancé voilà c'est ça oui ça peut être
ça peut être très grave
ça peut être très grave enfin c'était en
relativisant dans cette position là pour
l'instant des cinq tours des scènes
inattendues mais est recommandé par
l'ordinateur stéphane ah bon nous très
surprenant la menace est quoi f4 sur
vous aussi ça ordinateurs dix tours à 5
maintenant ils vont que chez f5 kasparov
c'est le coût qui empêche f5 stéphane ah
oui
ce simple défensif alors oui il veut
stabiliser la position dans un premier
temps relooking
celui qu'on nomme et le king bond qui
fut un jour à tour de ce qui va gagner
le pion à 104 dans tous les cas la ccel
c'est fini c'est sûr quel beau nom mais
surtout à celles qu'on peut vous pousser
trois non loin un nom ça mange pas
non mais là c'est le cadre alors que
l'ordinateur propose ici un point de
défense originale
oui on peut le montrer peut-être montré
la voie là aussi saucisses la tour vient
bien entendu on a cinq
voilà à noter que les noirs évidemment
ne peuvent pas jouer est discrètement il
faut 500 prises oui et maintenant le
coup c'est ça qui est alors proposée par
mois ou par la machine surprenant
surprenant c5 et la tour prend ses 5
alors là il faut des canapés ça marche
pas et oui il faut des quatre échecs à
oui pas mal si la tour prend solution il
le fou s'activerait en d4 c'est ça et
ensuite on passerait le peut-être le roi
en dé 6,5
je ne sais pas c'est une possibilité
tout avec ses 5 dans cette position ça
n'a pas l'air complètement aberrant et
le nord pour réjouissent f5 prendre 1 4
et peut-être activer le fou de cases
blanches pour attaquer le pion b3 ouais
avec les attentions
ils sont forts les chroniques mais
attention et loire attention attention
attention gary plutôt oui attention un
regard une attention parce que si ça a
l'air dans le cycle au lieu d'un c'est
comme ça la position ultra mini qui peut
jouer fois aussi ses cinq ça alerte pas
si mal effectivement maintenant c'est
peut-être que kasparov espère aussi trop
fort ce kasparov
il tend des pièges à eelv a joué par
michael a joué ah oui il va jouer des
tours à huit après faut aussi faussement
sérieux c'est fait donc la question doit
jouer torah scène qu'est ce qu'on va
revenir comme un fou voilà c'est le seul
coup c'est le seul 3 5-7 seul coup
normal
en plus après les heures de réflexion il
a joué vite voilà 5
il l'a fait ça tout ça je vous la sage
où on va voir un plan est là là ils sont
deux à réfléchir c est parce que la
casse ne peut pas aussi menacé de venir
en a 8 pour aller ensuite à we know me f
5 est toujours assez un coin et s'active
le [ __ ] casques bleus moi j'ai peur de
ces fous peut-être ces saint-pierre là
mais c'est ça que c'est pas du tout
adhérent notre douleur terrible c'est
fou la loi et sont forts c'est fort ça
serait ça serait un désastre si kasparov
perdez mais peut-être est-ce que la
position ne serait pas avantage noir
finalement un tri je me serais
surprenant après le plan que ça serait
quand même surprenant parce que non et
pour gagner cette position dont les
noirs qui imagine ce qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent
oui mais comment empêcher les noirs
d'activer leurs pièces est ce que le
plan de chronique c'est pas simplement
de jouer roi des 6 3 6 6 3 b 6 non le
plan c c'est 5 f 5 est passé le fou
dernière est ensuite amené droit mais
oui ça c'est un pan simple en est
ça a pas l'air ça a pas l'air facile
pour les pour les blancs ça quand même
parce que la tour elle gambade mais elle
toujours attaquée par les fous à tour
gambade gamble travaille d'ailleurs sur
le point de nommer 600 salles embête
chronique parce qu'il veut jouer le roi
il veut amener le roi à l'attack je ne
sais pas peut-être il a plusieurs idées
que si on joue ces scènes qu'on empêche
le roi non avec certaines familles casf
qu'est ce qu'on vous parce qu'on lui en
achetant qu'il est en prise quand même
par la tour après quoi f4 banon mais
après n'importe quel coup c'est les
noirs peuvent plus rien faire s'il joue
pas c'est 5,6 nouera des six jeux pour à
ses cinquièmes jo il a joué six et cinq
ans la veille a joué bien jouer vladimir
alors le piège évidemment on va montrer
tout de suite si kasparov prend le pion
ici et bien tout simplement fou échec et
la tour est perdu nancras parfois jouer
tout de suite mais évidemment il l'a vu
que cette vie des joueurs ou a320 v33
voilà c'est 5 3 3 ça semblerait forcer
les noirs à jouer fou des quatre échecs
ou rodez 6 euros des six mois des six a
fait nul non pourquoi les blancs sont
nuls quand ils veulent oui mais de toute
façon
comme dit qu'il n'est pas là
spécialement pour gagner en même temps
mais attention parce que on s'en fout
des quatre chèques ou 20 euros
kasparov ça la question quand même je
sais pas mais c'est important quoi mais
attention à la menace des blancs et loi
après roi des trois voiliers cb4 cb4 il
faut s'en prémunir
o o pourquoi cb4 on va l'expliquer et
bien parce que si on prend en main je
vous faut être deux évidemment d'emprise
je vous fais deux en levant le plus fou
de la prise
et là c'est pas mal oui mais peut-être
tout simplement des 4 des cas très loin
des 4 quand même web et 4 quand même on
a vibré y croira bcap merci si c'est pas
mal parce que plus on prend et la tour
35 me masturber 5 et récupère le pion
oui
des petits problèmes pour chronique des
petits problèmes là petit petit mais des
problèmes des problèmes des problèmes
pour trois ans de kasparov pas si simple
pas si simple comme hajri crâne nick
wade si c'est pas mal non
sa dernière ronde et si ce salaire mieux
ça va quand même leur mieux mais il y
avait qu il n'y a pas eu 4 2 sur 4 on se
fout des catéchètes qui on est plutôt
content d'avoir forcé pion avancé aux
24es papier imprimé roi des trois on me
laisse toujours b4 pas clair et puis
après beisheim créé loi et le fou de
cases noires déjà pu arrêter le pion ont
difficilement et puis le coup de cases
blanches alors serez fiat est ce qu'on
peut envisager stéphane on peut
l'envisager de toute façon c'est le
couscous et 3 oui on peut toujours
l'envisager parce que là il y aurait
probablement tour à 6 échecs 3 6 3
recettes et la rue des trois qui
affluent des quatre il a fait voile à
l'école et je fous des garde-fous doigts
et les juifs ou des 4 tu le roi restera
aux sept mois là le roi pour l'instant
sept coups des quatre chèques prévoir
trois fous des quatre échecs qu'a sport
va probablement jouer le coup droit en
d3 et ça ça change tout est-ce que la
menace est oui
voilà voilà non il ya encore des petits
coups à jouer là et encore des petits
coups à jouer
bah
alors quel sport peut jouer peut-être
roi des trois menaçant peut-être b4
leroy t3 on va voir ça avant alors là on
peut se poser la question de ce qui se
passe après f5 un petit rêve simple mais
monsieur je suis pas grave ça des cas
très loin des quatre d'accord maintenant
prend aux 4 on prend le cas très bien au
roi prend ou paie en préemption prend au
choix donc tu veux sur mon parcours
empruntant plus logique quand même ouais
mais on se heurte avec cinq échecs n'ont
peut-être on va prendre une option sega
tempe arizona ouais donc tenu des
conditions proches voilà et la m5 le roi
des 6 9 5 kg à rodez 6 3 2 6 3 décider
si c'est la question est qui est mieux
question et qui mieux b5 voilà
maintenant les 5o est l'idée c'est de
créer un pion passé ouais mais là je
pense pas que les noirs risque quoi que
ce soit pour une raison très simple tout
leur temps sont défendus et les blancs
ne peuvent pas créer d'autres y ont
passé que ceux qui ont des 5
bref pas de problème il n'y a pas
davantage pour l'un ou l'autre
attention à ce que les noirs peuvent pas
s'activer dangereusement en jouant un f5
et cinq ici pour l'énerver saint maurice
a beaucoup et 5 1
imaginons f5 parce que lifesize menace
pions prend le cas tu vie de fou prince
et 4 et 5 c'est très fort avantage noirs
ici c'est probable c'est probable
non c'est pas clair c'était c'est pas
très clair
donc c'est chaud donc c'est chaud pour
l'instant c'est très chaud à noter que
derrick laisse pas filer très fine comme
away et pouvoir les jouer à mort pour
une fois il a joué il a trouvé un point
original et a trois enfants sympathique
pour jouer cette finale avec tour contre
de fou si 14 jours avec 4 est ce que
trame il va jouer food et s'il faut cinq
échecs
bah c'est pas mieux oui y'a pas mieux
oui ces cas là c'est nul parce que là
c'est mieux puisque et au le roi est
obligé de venir en trois sets et cela
ils n'entendent réfléchir à ce qu'est ce
qu'il envisage pourquoi est-ce qui vous
permettront en d3 qu'est ce qui le
chagrine comme ça mais il peut y avoir
des menaces de matellois fous ces trois
menaces ou des deux matt panne on est
pas mal mais ça oblige le roi revenir en
g3 c'est vrai c'est quand même même si
cette fois il ya quand même temps france
et 5 c oui c'est pas forcément bienvenue
au nom et pas de maths
non donc en fait j'ai cru à matran toi
mais pourquoi pourquoi tu espères quoi
phishing parce que s'ils vont en d2 il
menace rien maintenant il va aller en d3
mais pourquoi il réfléchit alors les
molaires f4 n'a pas valablement cftc
page 4 pourquoi ça fait nul oui non mais
j'ai réfléchi et non mais peut-être un
jour autrement il reste perdant non non
non non mais ici ça son visage quand
même au ras du tout pourquoi je veux
dire oui pourquoi justement nommée life
5 f 5 e et 5 e bah ouais ça n'a pas
l'air plus compliqué que ça ipsen
captivant le fou de cases blanches
compréhension prend on reprend fascine
qui est mieux possible pour ramener
qu'une fois de plus c'est la même
annonce est plus la même là on a une
meilleure structure rupture n'était pas
mon jour b4 quand même et après 3 des 6
on joue b5
qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas intérêt à
changer les pions plus tôt avait les
blancs parce que hélas il ya quand même
une structure qui bien vieillir a bien
évidemment puisque avant l'option
n'était pas en f3 mais on veut 4 dans la
banque quoi c'est d'abord aimé
l'attention et loi fourre 8 6 oui sauf 6
ça doit perdre assez vite après taux à
six échecs et dé 6,6 à terre où
s'affairent mais bon il ya deux
possibilités pour les autres
possibilités pour les noirs la mefou
aussi ici on peut faire flouer 6,3 des
trois faux échec
ouais c'est ça il faut faire mieux comme
tondeuses et poindre enfin que faire
quand on veut mais on peut jouer pour le
gagner peut-être non est ce que c'est
possible
ils ne risquent rien les noirs il ne
reste aux la chronique ici au losc
lorient donc moralité et bien nous voilà
nous y sommes
nous avons tous compris à cette position
stefan wey au roi fou des catéchètes way
que kasparov viennent en d3 ou en d2 les
noirs s'en foutent ils jouent f5
bref ensuite il échange ils ont à [ __ ]
et vanadium sur f5 des scop les blancs
ne peuvent pas jouer le coup curieux e5
très curieux oui mais dans le côté le
fcm clôture noir gêne plus les noirs
pour l'instant et le pion et 5 peut pas
être pris à cause de tout reprendre ses
scènes
alors nous allons envisager cette
position avec le ppte avec l'euro en d3
endroits des trois f 5 f5 et là je
propose également la position de 5
du jamais vu curieux mais bon très
curieux
parce que sur foot 17 aujourd'hui
éventuellement tour à six nations le
tournage 6 alors c'est moi c'est un vrai
numéro 5 ouais mais on récupère la purge
cinq oui on vous 17 cbl 17 c'est bien
avec des grossistes non mais faut déjà
ça va pas ce pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi on se fout des scènes et bien
jouer de 4,4 voilà peut-être très
difficile à croire
voir maintenant on joue pas tant attendu
regardons quelques instants de l'indus
sa voleuse amérique ne détourne un avis
sur son canal veulent je vous rappelle
fossé 6 stéphane continuons quelques
coups non c'est pas c'est pas bon si
c'est intéressant en études t'on pu
attaquer donc tous jugés 3 et maintenant
je mets le fou en quatre avec échec avec
et chérie qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit
de fugu très simple très intéressant
très intéressant mais c'est une
possibilité
ouais mais bon je sais pas quand je sens
que c'est pas une belle perspective
difficile à juger ce type de greffe
ici ça y est fou des cartes et chèques
et chroniques peinard karnik et
tranquille il est tranquille d'admirer
quelques parfums jours à détroit comme
stéphane il a joué gros titres on a
oublié le voilà ça y est il vient de jeu
des droits des trois casses provient de
jouets de cour à detroit alors on
propose pour kramnik le coup f5 pour
activer les pièces et on se fout de b4
c'est ça ou est-ce qu'il va pas jouer le
f2 s'il veut pas permettre b4 non non je
reste inquiet
ils veulent faire vadimir bidon pendule
40 minutes restantes pour cramique 15
octobre pour kasparov et donc qu'elle
peut encore repasser le top
il semblerait qu'ils posent des
problèmes chroniques là dans cette
finale et faut dire qu'hormis que
réfléchie une heure sur pour jouer
fuglsang
quand même très curieux est-ce que
kramnik plus gaffe et dans cette finale
c'est curieux parce que vu la tête 2k
sports tout à l'heure et est quand même
loin de la gaffe d3s que mais attention
f5 et loi mais attention je propose f5
voile ajoutons qu est simple je joue mon
cou f5
voilà ça marche pas je pense ils à tours
à huit mais le fou des quatre contrôles
c'est sous des capes contrôler tout à
fait non mais si après 9,5 c'est clair
il faut impérativement que les blanchons
b3 b4 éclater si terrible ils sont
obligés de jouer ça que font les noirs
ça aurait déjà vu stéphane rupture
provocatrice mais quand même maintenant
on avait regardé si on prend qui avait
pas l'air de problème on jouait la rue
youri aura procès lyon apprend il
reprend peut-être en france est mieux
sur contout roi des six comprend pas le
pion 6,4 à nombre des sinistrés bien
pourquoi on défend de lancer cinq rendez
si c'est bien ça pose des problèmes ici
ça pose de gros problèmes aux blancs
je sais pas qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
les mauriciens
si on prend c'est ça qu'il faut français
sagna menace faux prince et 4 menacé
france et 4 on peut pas jouer les
simples encore rien faire tours à 6
échecs pour assister chèque oui le roy
on revient on le sait tous on décède
peut-être est sûr et là peut-être
mais peut-être pas aussi je sais pas ça
va pas je ne sais pas si facile facile
facile travnik un bas alors pourquoi
qu'est ce qui se passe en fait tout
simplement à partir du coup f5 et bien
on s'aperçoit dans cette position que
les pions blancs les d'options blanc là
ne sont pas même d'avancer les diagonale
des fous sont en train de s'ouvrir et
donc le roi blanc commence à se
retrouvent en difficulté il est mis en
échec un peu tout le temps ouais mais là
il ne retrouve pas mms furie gagner ça
c'est clair mailly sur une mauvaise
défense de kasparov qui peuvent espérer
gagner d'à priori objectivement qu'elle
se profile sent quand même le moment où
sa position bascule de un peu moins un
peu mieux à égal et conseil ali gila de
joie pour le guerre en général
enfin là dans la situation d'un match
peut-être le pousser à essayer de trois
astuces de 3 combinent en mutation ighil
c'est ça il est dos au mur la casse pas
c'est clair
moi stéphane je crois que c'est la
partie dans le match comme on a les plus
longues réflexions consécutive
ah ouais ouais là c'est terrible mais
demain ça va s'accélérer forcément ils
resteront en miss fénols côté ils ont
gagné tellement de temps en jouant veuf
ou très vite que là ils sont 20 par zain
note
les animaux se sont même pas passés sous
la barre des 3 millions de parcours g ni
que super pensif veut dire j'aurais dû
regarder ma berlinoise a choisi nul plus
vite même plus facile avec la berlinoise
oui il aura pas une deux autres partis à
tenir avec les noirs kremnica ouais mais
bon flic et 26 nuls mais voilà en plus
ils veulent vallée du lot il continue
peut-être encore joué pour gagner
oui il va continuer à chaud pour le cas
c'est ce que rapporte profil n'a pas
résolu ses problèmes c'est pas parce que
kramnik al avance qu' il faut se
relâcher avec les noirs kasparov allons
allons
s'est pas fait enfin si fait nul ici je
pense que demain ecublens
une petite news lui déplairait pas trop
hein pas demain samedi c'est nul ça m'a
dit avec les blancs non mais il va jouer
pour le gain et 28,6 l'intérêt parce que
plus la partie difficile pour caspar en
plus c'est dur pour caspar de rejouer
dimanche et on a un peu plus on a
l'impression kasparov est très fatigué
kramnik a l'air de bien dormir lui il
faut qu'il n'est prise un crâne idole
est épuisé le poisson oui c'est ça c'est
ça joue aussi évidemment on lâche et du
beau temps qui pose de gros problèmes à
kasparov et bien continuer d'épuiser
mentalement psychologiquement ça c'est
un facteur du match c'est un facteur
important
c'est un peu comme on n'en prendra pas
de parler de foot mais c'est important
mais c'est le quand on commence à perdre
beaucoup de matches qu'on gagne plus
mais il ya la confiance s'en va et c'est
pareil aux échecs il faut re motiver
je sais que si on n'est pas motivé sinon
si on en a perdu la confiance et bien on
joue moins bien c'est exactement la même
chose
bon alors est-ce que chronique peut pas
jouer le coup
ici il va jouer face à un travelling
wave 2 points sans idées dans cette
position il a envie de jouer comme des
fous et f2 pas mal on y va jouer il faut
qu'ils nous ouvrent les caisses de ces
fous pourquoi pas faux f2 sa menace peut
être de l'un des fiefs de on l'a déjà vu
on va dire j -c loin un coup conceptuel
si sa menace 3 des 6 es ab qui assassine
mais on prend les quatre missions
tremblay quatre taureaux holstein
oui j'aime bien passer la loi
oui mais je vais le manger non parce que
tu perds h4 non mais je veux manger
quand même et je joue par exemple b3 b3
je ne travaille joop vous prend 1 h 4
points 4
et là je fais la petite finesse way qui
fait très mal
des couples g4 avec l idée avec l'idée
s'est fixé n'a pas ça s'est fixée un oui
je n'ai piqué b3 alors tu n'iras c'est
pas évident que ça gagne pour les blancs
même c'est pas sûr que les plans soient
abstenus
ouais enfin c'est possible et c'est
qu'au lieu de g4 ya peut-être d'autres
possibilités non g4 ça a l'air pas mal
c'est vrai il peut jouer au s2 aussi
chrome mais bon pourquoi se priver des
f-5 way peut-être c'est ça la question
dans cette position évidemment c est qu
on veut jouer
elle sent que ça va ouvrir la diagonale
de ce fou aussi ça c'est très important
stéphane c'est juste
baticle
comme dirait mon ami helmut ton ami
helmut el mout that's clair d'accord
c'est très clair bon alors là on a droit
dans mes quatre amis que les jeunes
prennent il ya il avait presque une
heure d'avancé et là il est en train de
passer sous il a intérêt à voir tableau
il amène ton quart d'heure de retard
chronique énorme il sait que le match
est à sa portée la cif nuls dans cette
partie il et il est très détendue
thiefaine dans cette partie quand même à
force de se dresser comme ça il va finir
par perdre autant non mais il a problème
vu que f5 s'adonner nul rapide des
choses comme ça ça donne et une houle
quasi forcée
innocent assuré non mais bon on peut pas
imaginer stéphane je pense que personne
à la jouais bien je le vladimir ouais
m'enfin bon il ya mis du temps un nom
mais bon ce qui compte c'est pas d'issue
mais c'est le combat ouais enfin bon et
a mis du temps quand même là il va y
aller c'est quand même étonnant quoi
pour jusqu'où qui a l'air il a joué cinq
rames nique et il est parti et il est
parti à la casse par an va-t-il faire il
faut jouer des quatre n'a pas le choix
prendre l'a5 d'abord pottow émanant
d'hommes il faut prendre avec échec ce
qui menace les noirs les mains libres
pour jouer ou f2 ensuite toute cette
mécanique réfléchi longtemps parce
qu'ici c'est un énorme casse parfois des
risques fasse pas offrant des risques
qui me laisse jouer f5 il me laisse
active de mai fu il joue avec le feu
gary peut-être que l'ail cramique
commence à penser à le finir
tu penses c'est possible c'est possible
en tout cas c'est clair que les change
de ce pion aux 4 va adoucir la pression
bah ça va éclaircir la situation avec
tertiaire ça va libérer le fou de cases
blanches un petit peu ça va donner un
peu plus de cases et ça ça donne de
l'air et c'est bien
je me casse par an 1,6 g league fait nul
il y est il y as part of a oui il y est
complet et ce classement faut pas jouer
eux 5
il faut 17 c'est ça c'est le sexe à
manas peut-être non ça me serait du tout
en fait c'est vraiment le coup qu'il
faut pas jouer alors là que propose
notre ami là ils proposent une position
complètement égal il propose des 4 b 4
avec une position complètement notre ami
c'est donc l'ordinateur en train de
l'ordinateur ce que nous l'aimons bien
parce qu'on sait jamais on vérifie avec
nous qu'avec lui on est sûr de pas rater
un gain de pions ou d'enfourcher un coup
de fourchette en trois coups comme ça
c'est clair
alors 1 11
et
tu
le funky
il faut que les sports jeux b4 je pense
bekaert salaires on voit tellement plus
l'idée que comme on est obligé de
proposer des coûts et quatre non mais
c'est pas mal des quatre sacres un pion
passé parce que si les noirs prennent
d'emblée quatre évidemment le nord les
v-noirs prêts dans le cas très cher
comme chez elle pose la question on va
prendre ça a l'air d'être le plus
teigneux way et là on avait regardé le
courant des sinistres tout simplement
non mais faut penser qu'un intrus bon
alors on prend ces quatre c'était femmes
c'est pas évident on ne s'est produit
que l'autre ce n'est pas si évident
impression français 5 qu'est ce que je
fais et bien après on prend six semaines
je joue simplement le coup par exemple
le coup je sais pas - le coup fourré f2
non il faut deux possibles également
60 le pion va jamais à dame ouais mais
oui non et pour pourquoi ça alors qu'on
peut faire mieux c'était fait tu veux
dire on peut c'est de gagner
oui c'est ça ce que je veux dire c'est
que dans cette position là on n'est pas
obligés de prendre l'option c'est quoi
le roi décide qui a toujours n'en ont
gagné jamais il y a toujours tour à 6
échecs
ah oui toi ça propose la nuit le aux
blancs tout de suite oui mais d'accord
mais au moins si les blancs prenant ces
cinq c'est une toute autre histoire
on leur donne pas deux ans passés sur
lequel ces cinq ça sert à rien de toute
façon au roi décide c'est le coup plus
logique ici il se passera un espace rien
tout simplement oui gepci à tour à 6
échecs 3,6 et chaque province est
l'institution de choix je pense que les
deux positions sont nuls
c'est une question de choix de joueurs
il ne se passe rien et donc voilà si b4
on prend 1 4 6 6 e 5 et bien 5 c'est
chaud c'est la fameuse rolex ou 17 ou le
faut bien se replacer le roi menace de
21 ans aussi c'est voilà donc
possibilité donc on a vu des quatre
maintenant la possibilité c'est 2,5 sur
quoi il ya fou 17
la menace c'est de monter le rwanda 6
puis de prendre 5 et 6 les blancs sont
amenés à jouer le coup à fond 4 eh bien
on se fout c'est 6 suivi trois ou quatre
échecs est de fous merveilleusement
installé bref ici
après le couac de crown ikeda caspar
affiliés il peut plus passer il va
probablement cerner le tram ni crise ni
d'une fois de plus
on va encore essayer quelque chose il
reste 40 minutes
kasparov contre 32 à chroniquer il a
joué les jouer il est joué quoi il veut
b4 il a joué b4 kasparov
voilà pourquoi il a joué b4 petite
proposition j'étais resté sur les
joueurs parce que ça peut s'arrêter de
jouer parce que c'est encore un peu
tactique la b4 asiatique ses chroniques
qui est penché sur l'échiquier et
kasparov qui est un peu en retrait
inversion de rôle mes chroniques
kasparov a pas montré d'exceptionnel
dans cette partie krainik qu'est-ce qui
m'accueille prof
je peux faire
hypothèse selon laquelle ces infos
kasparov redevient reste d'actualité
oh oui non mais c'est clair c'est
peut-être un fou kasparov
ce qui expliquerait tout le fameux
modèle démodé qu'on avait refusé de
sortir en match de moscou 84 ans est la
nouvelle version est en donc une
quelques avaries
il ressort des cadres wade b4 pourquoi
pas dès 14 ans menée qui va jouer me
surprend et théâtre échec c'est clair
suivi droit des six bébés singes qu'on a
un pion passé avec les blancs quand même
non ouais mais les cinq il ya deux ans
et quatre ans prédit stéphane c'est tout
moi même jamais non jamais après avoir
relaté à trois as tu veut en prendre qu
à prendre du plomb ouais mais aussi la
réplique qui ont passé c'est l'horreur
c'est complètement approuvant un bien
sûr que si on va faire des pme passé
puisqu'on va avoir un peu poussée à
gauche et c'est tout
dans certaines 34 je refuse de croire
que kasparov est prévu de reprendre avec
le pion on peut le regarder quand même
toute façon le coup qu'on attend d'eux
kramix et celui là c'est vrai ouais tu
me prends pions là stéphane propose de
prendre avec l'option oui pour laisser
le droit d'être en voilà et garder le
contrôle sur l'option c4 voilà ça c'est
l'idée mais bon ici ça a pas l'air de
porter des offres il a pris l'afrique
running wilde il a pris un cap il a pris
un cadre là donc la position
actuellement qu est ce qu on va revenir
peut-être le gros plan sur les joueurs
puisqu'il ne faut pas rater
éventuellement une proposition de nuls
kramnik viennent de prendre quatre et il
faut faire un plein sur les joueurs
puisque il va peut-être proposer nul ici
à garry kasparov
non c'est pas mais c'est possible il
faut se préparer ce pas on va revenir en
tout cas vous kasparov peut proposer
aussi alors ça arrange lequel des
joueurs évidemment kramnik l'annulent
ans stéphane tsassis un marrant ça
serait que des sports propose nommés
communistes lui dise joue ton coup
d'abord tôt pour savoir
ah non attention pas de propositions
atteint sur qui on prend 1,4 à mon avis
que kasparov a choisi de choisy il a
choisi ce qu'il va faire là quand il
s'est avancé sur sa chaise
rami ne veut pas le lâcher un
à
tatata d'abord
kasparov peut faire un roi prend pions
ou puis on prend des droits il peut
aussi jouer au roi de gracier de loin ce
sont tous les trois des deux aussi il ya
cinq ou légaux non seulement votre ego
pour parer les chèques on prend le pion
et le pion ou avec le roi ça fait deux
ou alors le roi sur la casse et de d2 ou
eu deux cas soir dans un fichier
réfléchir à 5 ou possible il y en a
trois qui l'éliminent assez vite donc en
fonction du temps que kasparov a
réfléchi vous pourrez calculer le nombre
de coups que quelques strophes calcul à
la seconde
et oui donc là par exemple il est une
moyenne assez faible puisque ça fait
déjà presque une minute qui réfléchit en
stéphane ce qu'il faut quand même dire
pour un peu réfuté la théorie c'est que
kasparov dans visage pâle catholique où
elle avance une voie beaucoup de
variantes sur chacun de ses coups niveau
à tous les coups de rame nique tous les
siens tout se trame unique tous les
saints et ainsi de suite pendant assez
longtemps ce qui fait qu'elle soir
calcul très vite en fait sera fait
prendre l'homme sur terre qui calcule de
mieux et chroniques
un de ceux qui comprennent le mieux le
jeu d'échecs qui sont capables de jouer
toutes les positions
quand et qui il a l'air de rien mais qui
a vraiment l'air de rien il n'a même pas
l'air de mesure et de m quand on le voit
comme ça en fait c'est un géant il a 25
ans il est très grand s'il est très très
fort il est vraiment très fort puisqu'il
arrive à tenir
garry kasparov en cage depuis le début
de ce match d'expérience n'est pas passé
une seule fois n'a pas gagné une partie
est pour l'instant la pression
actuellement kasparov a le choix entre
plusieurs possibilités soit rampillon
swaptions prend pions et dans les deux
cas il peut proposer mieux royales air
serein chronique bilan pendule 37
minutes restantes à garry kasparov 30
minutes pour chronique stéphane est ce
qu'on aura droit une fois de plus c'est
nul
à un art qui cherchent ils cherchent
sarov cherche une solution
ah bah on court on ya cru on a failli
jouer on a même été arrêtée par sa
chemise petit oeillades
alors que ce n'est que les mains de
chroniques à eux il ya de nouveau après
il ya des sports en flat classement nous
fait le coup de feu yade
mais le diable qui veut dire tu crois
que c'est nul c'est peut-être raison
thales le vérifier non mais est-ce que
c'est nul nul c'est sur ça parce que je
sais pas peut-être ou ou la wii
oeillades là on sent sa cent vingt ans
stéphane quelque chose de louche
oui un arrangement à il a rien dit il a
rien dit kasparov
il a rien dit il a pris du roi un
arrangement une petite nul donc un hic
cependant qu'un arrangement est ce que
kramnik fait une gaffe qui serait un
autre à un autre type d'arrangement la
famille de convenance kramnik fouilles
de gaffes qui serait un arrangement
voilà par exemple crown et qui va jouer
des cinq échecs et on s'en fout de son
emprise oui il déclaré à la conférence
je ne crains ni jour est éventuellement
d'après certaines rumeurs ici à londres
jouerie maintenant fou des cinq échecs
et après roy prend fou abandonnerait et
déclaré à la conférence de presse je ne
l'avais pas vu voilà c'est des bruits
qui courent mais bon c'est un peu gros
quand même cette boue 14 ça pas très
content désignera mais ce que kraft peut
pas jouer le coup à jouer rodez lestonan
c'était page ou c3 mais une belle
redessine ces trois noms il peut je me
faisais soir non mais il peut faire
mieux dans tous les sens ramener non
mais faut ces trois ça fait nul tout de
suite vous êtes mon salaire comme al
match de c3 ça fait nul tout de suite et
loire on va montrer la variante pouces
et 3 nuls tout de suite de chroniques
puisque surtout ces trois le pion b4 et
attaquer il faut prendre ces cinq avec
la tour et là tout simplement fou prend
et la tour doit rester sur la colonne
c'est sinon après coup des six solutions
c4as leur emprise peut-être tourbe et 5
non ton prochain et tu en prends le sexe
des femmes quand le 5 mai pions sur
france 5
ça ça donne une finale typiques comme
c'est nul ça probablement nulle
ouaip rendre en chine alors non mes
chroniques à jouer il faut être deux
kamikazes le chef de file de il a joué
ouais il a je me faisais dans cette
position il a pris 1,24 donc alors on a
pris un peu vieux maintenant ou elf de
l'essence kasparov avec deux pions
emprise le cube et 4 est en prise le en
trois pions aux prises le pied levé 4 le
pian c4 le pion h4 où l'alors mais comme
dit le proverbe on ne peut prendre
qu'une seule pièce attaque les parcours
où la langue ou l'autre quête de
kasparov il est pas mus couffo f2
n'aurait pas vu moi mais c'est pas grave
il a joué de dépenser 5
c'est très probable et après le dépenser
5 g nicklas il a que des choix plaisant
oui je vous prends h quatre noms proches
4 c'est très probable sain parce que les
pions doublé de toute façon se voit être
pris c'est sûr
facile null null duo les objectifs
surprenant ce petit coucou à f2 quand
même on s'attendait à voir des six dans
cette position quand mika des ses dettes
le club 2 ça va être nul c'est son choix
lulu rallye c'est sûr ça va être nul on
voit mal chronique se tromper comme ces
femmes
pour moi les crânes ligue se tromper
part of on va revenir de là gros plant
parce qu'il peut y avoir nulle à tout
moment là peut y avoir nulle c'est sûr
et oui c'est possible
lacasse part aux recherches
on
castro recherche mais ne trouve pas les
noirs simplifie la position et
obtiennent une nulle facile est-ce que
tours plus pignon contre de fous n'ont
rien faire puisque le fou sacrifie
contre le mieux à la 36e
au pirée dans la question c'est tour
plus d'options contre de fou c'est ça la
question même si jamais il ya tout juste
deux plombiers jamais non mais c'est une
question de philosophie que cephalon
puisque là les mêmes tours plus de pions
sur deux autres durant
ça va être dur
ce prof
ou alors il réfléchit mais à quoi ils
peuvent réfléchir si ces raids
c'est nul dans fr a priori kramix à
trouver une solution pour forcer la nuit
maintenant on crée sport peut jouer roi
des 3 e en d3 et qu'est ce que ça
apporte
eh bien il ya profusion prend b4
avait-on brands hatch 5 pour prendre
cinq et ils gardent peut-être des
options minimale mais pour des trois
hommes et c'est le seul coup pour
essayer de faire quelques accents
bientôt un combinant quand même ça
ressemble beaucoup bidon à detroit ce
roi des trois peut-être trois des six
peut-être des six en souplesse
ouais peut-être
pourquoi rodez s'ils sont venus en scène
steve hill road on va défendre l'option
c5 tout simplement menaçant pour h4
ouest-france nathan menace on lâche rien
du tout ça sera vrai on va décider c'est
vraiment le coup bidon oui s'il faut
rien faire il faudrait faire je vais
rien faire alors là non c'est bon d'être
au service non oui mais quoi faire
d'autre mais non monsieur cuisse et des
peurs en tirer de cette position
kasparov ne passera pas voilà c'est sûr
maintenant on vous l'annonçait voilà
s'il passe eh bien on se casse non
kasparov ne va faire nul c'est sûr qu'au
rien faire cram me voilà il a l'air
super détendu vous le voyez ici tout à
droite de l'écran
legrand krainik hyper détendu il regarde
le plafond il attend que ça se termine
non mais c'est sur tf1 on va pas comme
en classe peut respirer passer ça c'est
complètement
c'est bien dommage avait que deux points
de plus c'est pas de chance gary c'est
râlant et finalement le coup h4 de
kasparov bien s'avère une faiblesse oui
en fait partie oui mais vous toute façon
il aurait été seul c'était un ami qui
était en tête c'était encore pire dont
je pense pas que h4d en fait ce qui
embête kasparov sais pas ce qui fait la
tête c'est que kramnik fait nul quand il
veut s'ils avaient des sports cette
chronique fin d'une facile quand il veut
à chaque fois et voilà est par contre
quand ils allaient blanc kasparov lui ne
sait pas quand jouer et kasparov gagne
kramnik gagnent quand il veut aussi
c'est terrible alors ça ça devient
ennuyeux mais ça devient vraiment
ennuyeux il a beau bout des gaspards on
fait bien la vérité de kramnik semble
plus forte que la sienne
ça c'est pour ça et bien aujourd'hui
encore une fois kasparov ne trouva rien
n'a rien trouvé et ne trouvera pas on
n'a pas eu droit
là
crâne lisse et trop fort et il sera
probablement le 14e champion du monde
d'échecs avec à venir on règne solide
puisqu'on voit pas qu'il va pas de
chronique allant là bas
non mais on sait déjà qu'il a déjà battu
c'était shirov kamski guildford oui les
français 5 alors attention il ya
peut-être une proposition de nulle la
non non pour acheter 34 ça joue sajou on
va rester sur les joueurs ont lâché 4 et
chef sait si c'est si c'est si ça tape
ça attaque lâche 5 ans restons quand
même son tour youssa histoire très
bizarre secousses et 6 non ce qui est
bizarre c'est que chronique et laisser
jouer non marqués non ça a l'air
complètement rim stéphane un salaire
salaire archi nulle question vous faire
[ __ ] en c4 au roi de sicile soumettre
le roi devant les pions maintenant trois
des six mais tout reprend à 110,6 comme
ça t'en prends h5 d'accord va jusqu'au
bout kasparov
il en a marre il avait mais pourquoi il
n'a pas fait depuis le début alors jeune
jusqu'au bout ah oui et peut-être
fawcett dans cette position il faut
c'est tout simplement la position et 7 6
c'est comme ça voilà ici rien n'est joué
par gary on attend roi des six de
vladimir kramnik probablement
effectivement un défi c'est calais
revient très logique
sur quoi kasparov a priori il devrait
prendre cinq oui et là maintenant un
coup comme fou aux 7 c'est pas mal
fawcett et tous les pions blancs sont en
prise et mais ça peut créer encore il ya
toujours de plus en plus c'est loin
donc voyez dans la fameuse finale touré
de pion entre deux fous pareils kasparov
a montré qu'il était capable d'échanger
les pions pour l'instant dans cette
partie et donc de terminer tous adopter
un autre oui de fou mine de rien mais
c'est moi le problème c'est qu'il y aura
des échecs partout oui bah oui mais non
mais le problème reconnaissent et que le
roi va se mettre devant pions les
fourons look et l'autre
ça devrait être nulle non ça va être nul
6-6 les plus en plus en plus c'est même
pas de contrainte parce que là il ya
effectivement il ya deux contraints de
ce côté là et avancer ses deux pions
rouge contre deux fous ça allait être
très dur ça va être très dur effrayant
non là on voit pas comment quelqu'un
mais presque on peut essayer
on ne sait jamais et chroniques peuvent
faire une gaffe possible mais qu'elle
soit en fossiles peut faire une gaffe à
tes actions qu'elle se lance dans la
mode plus fatigué quand même et on
dirait que les blancs ne peuvent pas
perdre parce qu'il faudrait vraiment
faire une grosse enfilade un truc un
très gros quoi le gros truc quoi alors
qu' il faudra vraiment faire un gros
truc mais oui il est blanc peuvent pas
perdre donc en fait il peut jouer
tranquillement jusqu'au bout les noirs
peuvent perdre maintenant la défense
semble assez facile
peut-être dans les mains les deux cas
les cas moderne
à la question faites en train de dire
akrami qu'aujourd'hui bon ok tu mènes 2
0 maintenant je vais jouer toutes les
parties à fond jusqu'à qui est roi
contre roye jeu s'explique maintenant
les jeunes dors plus je ne dors plus
mais pas non plus toi donc là si je peux
ne pas dormir
eh bien je ne dormirai pas de place
était très sport qui va s'épuiser avant
kramnik se joue avec l'espoir fait déjà
aujourd'hui stéphanie la tête
il a l'air il al'air explosé et manière
explosive garry kasparov n'est plus
qu'un fantôme
il essuie travailler deux jours non stop
pour réfuter la berlinoise et s'est vu
opposer autre chose ça lui fait un coup
au moral quand mon petit gars et de sens
puisqu'il est dormions objet de la jouer
et kasparov qui se dit dans sa tête qui
vaut déjà les commentaires de ses
anciens amis ses anciens amis et vite
kasparov était un grand joueur a été un
grand champion du monde c'est vrai
kasparov a eu un rôle dans le neuf ce
trafic
et ça ça va énerver cela l'énervé
effectivement puisqu'on sait que
kasparov atteint planifié d'être
champion du monde jusqu'à ce que son
fils comprennent ce que ça veut dire oui
alors que son fils pour l'instant nous
quand on doit pas voir de comprendre
puisqu'ils ne parlent pas encore mais
qui deviennent autant parler et qui va
dire un peu pas papa pourquoi t'es
numéro 2 ou alors tu verras c'est qui
trament knicks experts les derniers ça
ça va ça va peut-être énervé casse par
an si son fils lui demande effectivement
papa qui sait se crame nick qui est
numéro 1 aux échecs s'avère intéressant
ce jeu je veux être champion du monde
comme krainik passage ne sert qu'à
ramener et oui ça ça va lui casser le
moral ça va énerver puisqu'il a annoncé
trop haut et fort que ça l'énervé voilà
beaucoup y réfléchit grave ni qui va
nous faire le coup de la gaffe lasse pas
possible il reste 24 minutes pour jouer
sept coups alors stéphane c'est quoi le
coût de la gaffe est bien là par exemple
les noirs on voit pas trop on voit pas
trop dans sa sagesse inc je sais quoi y
envoya piriac ou des 5 fu des cinq
échecs des 50 e le mentionnait ça serait
horrible si le foot venait sur la case
dessin c'est vraiment prise par une
option c4 par la torah 5 et par le roi 4
et ne serait pas défendu et après peut
en prendre fou et bien kramnik d'éclat
aurait paraît-il
je devrais être humain je n'avais pas vu
je ne l'aï pas vu et à priori ça
n'arrivera pas stéphane vous alors ce
serait un peu gros souffrir un peu gros
la fameuse grosse gaffe il doit jouer
comme ça trois des six bien joué et j'ai
eu peur un e on a vu on a vu qu'ils
avaient une pièce qui l'avait devancée
dans une case en diagonal tour prochain
tempo garry kasparov on va rester sur
les joueurs là c'est important waouh
tout reprend h5 kasparov bien décrite
aux repentis sympa de propositions pas
de proposition mais ça peut arriver d'un
moment il faut jouer le foulard set tu
penses il faut rester vigilant faut
jouer le fou n'importe où s'était fait
un nom g37 enlève deux comme on veut
tout est bon m6 peut être que tu as tf2
c'est une belle kf2 ce qui peut pas être
attaquée je vois bien cramé calais - de
wave 2 chez pas pour y terminer qu'il ya
presse compétition entre amis car tout
est changé de face il savait quel sport
choisir
il est résigné kasparov non ils jouent
pour le plaisir maintenant il y bientôt
à son endroit pour mon avenir j'en veux
pour mon argent
ah oui j'ai voulu ce championnat du
monde je joue toutes les parties à fond
c'est mon dernier championnat du monde
fait de jouer à fond voilà j'ai beau
livre je veux jouer je veux jouer les
coups je veux jouer je veux en profiter
c'est la dernière fois que je fais une
finale chercher on est toujours là alors
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent qu'est ce qui
va nous faire
vous avez envie d'un il a envie d'aller
une fois en avant là ça se voit et envie
de jouer à eau
ça va être deux on va reprendre s'en
fout il va l'amener en avant vers
kasparov vers la table de caspar brute
réfléchir je cherche idiot on ignorait
22 minutes pour celle ci couvre up when
the crown 2 c'est quoi c'est une belle
case pourquoi ces périmètres cage pour
moi bien parce qu'elle ne peut pas être
attaquée ce frein et puis le pion et
surtout les violets avaient signalé
pions c4 et emprises et c6 aussi adopté
ce port est énorme et le pion sicotte
comment tu protèges bas je pense que
kraft qui a planifié de prendre les
d'options à mon avis parce que là
comment tu protèges le plan c quatre et
bien été obligé de jouer 3 10-3 et sur
wade trois adhérents prendre ces six et
voilà aurélie stéphane après france et 4
france et quatre jours à penser si ça
fera un complexe rappelé rue des
trois-rois détroit ouais mais roy
détroit cette année ce n'est pas un coup
voici le seul coup c'est un bon coup
kasparov in the box passera par gary
laisse pas alors pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'on verrait ont posé nues il va
proposer c'est un méga star of joue
parce que les journalistes
à chaque fois ils demandent pourquoi
vous lire il ya une très belle question
enfin la partie précédente à une
réaction d'un journaliste qui demande ça
lui gary est ce que nous avons vu le
vrai kasparov ici oui j'en ai skié donc
entendu nos commentaires à propos du
sosie de garry kasparov
voilà la tête et kasparov si chaque fois
garé est un peu dépité il a dit mais de
toute façon je ne peux rien faire je
vous invite à revoir ce grand moment de
la conférence de presse
fichier de la neuvième partie soit moi
j'ai peut-être tourache si ce nom ouais
mais tous insistent en france et 6
et la f4 menaçant f5
voila voila quoi voilà rien du tout
travnik fait nul en sifflotant
krikor de fou c'est très fort et
chronique a su les garder mais c'est
marrant parce qu'on se demande comment
kasparov peut gagner une partie
après on se partie consécutive il n'y a
jamais eu aucune chance de gain on se
demande vraiment comment est-ce qu'il
peut gagner
bah oui mais jamais été ne serait-ce que
proche de la victoire à part dans une
partie ouais mais encore proche c'était
toujours eu et il y avait un plan plus
alors que le mental joue toujours un
petit avantage blanc qui en fait
n'existe pas un mais là il rencontre la
sagne ouais non mais ces rencontres
s'est longtemps qu'ils s'en aillent
faire en tant que ça n'était rendu
compte
non mais en fait il a suivi à peu près
le plan qu'on avait donné d'activer sa
tour pour prendre le pion h55 plan
donnent pas davantage aux blancs battre
annick et bien joué il a remis ces fous
aussi c'est le 5d case logic est stable
g4 à voilà il joue il faille tilff ait
encore un fait encore diaries style
fighting indiqué robert gates car il va
piquer il va piquer le son c'est si
simple stylo factice ou le pion c4est
loi c'est court mieux alors prendre
l'option c4 stéphane
c'est pas forcément évident puisque 4 6
échecs alors on peut montrer la variante
à ses intérêts sans fou prend ses
quartiers donc attention voilà la
position on attend le moins évidemment
roi préemption ces sites non faut
prendre l'a4
il y à tour achi c'est chaque stéphane
est alors faux et 6 il faut aussi c'est
maintenant je joue f4 et là les
problèmes commencent puisque f5 c'est la
menace
on l'a peut-être et je commence à
chasser des pièces c'est vrai c'est vrai
ce n'est pas forcément grave vous prions
ça peut tenir encore
ouais mais ça a l'air quand même
beaucoup plus sur des limites et
l'option le plus avancé
oui c'est vrai c'est une règle qu'on
peut recommander à nos internautes quand
c'est vrai c'est vrai quand vous avez le
choix entre deux tubes apprenait plus
dangereux trop n'est plus dangereux mais
ici c'est le plan 7 6 et puis là que
fait que ce pari que fait kasparov qui
jouent tous agissent par exemple on se
sert comme en france et celle non au
droit c'est ça il assure f4 confus marge
etc à quoi qu'est ce que l'ordinateur
mentionne tout reprend aussi si ce n'est
au alors attention c'est une belle
variante sous chrome os 6
oui mais maintenant que les lits des
rois le 5 et we are les deux pions passé
nous avions passé qui passaient et qui
risquent pas c'est parce qu'il faut
prendre le pion c4est et on joue
j'essaie gsm très vite bon bref avec des
petites chances de gain ah ah qu'est ce
que ça voudrait dire ça ah ouais et
kasparov qui a l'air est question qui
fait qui fait un peu le
il des fortifs il est furtif la wii
c'est pour ça qu'il fait donc qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire of no 14
qui se dit mais surtout rachis stéphane
on peut jouer 3 17
calmons nous au roi des six rodez
atteint 17 ouais mais attend non mais
oui mais qu'est-ce qui joue la wii est
ce qu'ils ont fait ou bien oui le pion
et toujours en prise et on encourage de
il a joué trois procès si ça a été jouée
tour h 2 alors après ses 6 il a joué
courage de tournage de jeu pour quoi
faire
alors là je pense qu'il faut faire
attention c'est fait à chaque fois qu'un
coup est joué ça serait bien de l'été
joueurs en gros quand même oui chaque
fois qu'il joue un coup oui parce qu'on
risque d'avoir une nulle à tout moment
pour ne pas rater
la poignée de main peut être la partie
de nom c'est sensé pas encore non c'est
pas encore ça sera encore la partie
décisive ça sera peut-être c'est à venir
sera menée qui est sûre chaud si c'était
un parti si on serait autrement plus
excités ouais mon excité quand même tout
excité tout excité
tours h2 joué par tes stars of insight
qu'est ce qui se passe sur fuji un gary
fight infogen tour j'ai deux foulées
autour j'ai donc on ça permet de jouer
jusqu'à 13 500 perdre g4 bon peut-être
fou j'ai trois noms stéphane c'est
logique aussi fous chez toi bats tout
est logique et et kasparov qui fait la
tête il va se battre kasparov il va
essayer de maintenir cette position a
refait ses essais kasparov en est réduit
à essayer de gagner des positions
ingagnable qui joue et quand il avait 5
ans ouais il savait déjà fermé le contre
kharkov
quand il était tout petit alan est
réduit à essayer deposit de gagner des
positions que je voulais collégiens dans
les écoles d'échecs notamment encore et
c'est possible parce qu'en corse on sait
que les échecs dans les écoles c'est
très développés puisque je crois que la
ligue de corse a signé une convention
avec les conseils généraux et régionaux
pour que je sais plus combien je crois
trois mille élèves suivent des cours
d'échecs et salué cette initiative c'est
vrai que les échecs contre l'échec
scolaire
bon alors que va faire cramer nique dans
cette position de collégiens un soir une
position collégiens et loi générale
parce que tu entends par une pression
comme à une finale qu'on joue enfin bon
évidemment avec plein d'erreurs mais
incomplète
oui non mais d'accord mais c'est si du
genre de finale il a l'air déprimé gary
qu'on joue contre là ça me fait de la
peine sur cette photo encore un sens sur
cette image
ouais
fennell gary ferait de la peine
chronique il est sûr de lui
c'est effrayant il reste 18 minutes
akram nique pour jouer les quatre
derniers coups contre 26 à kasparov
bref y'a pas de zain note pas de crise
d'autant les fans à ce qu'à ton avis ça
peut durer encore le montant voilà on en
a encore pour deux heures l'un deux
petites erreurs
non non ça va ça va bien de tout
terminer je pense que la vie de terminer
lesparre en fait c'est d'avoir kramnik à
la psychologie il reste à table et il
lui donne une mine de boulder il attend
la faute
granic jette un petit coup d'oeil à la
pendule il y aurait ce 17 minutes pour
jouer quatre comme ça va pas de gros
risques pour kramnik les deux joueurs
savent que c'est nul est très importante
puisque kramnik ayant deux points
d'avance kasparov n'aura plus que deux
fois les blancs devraient impérativement
essayer de gagner les deux parties sous
peine de voir tous ces espoirs réduit
quasiment à néant
pour ça qu'il est inquiet cramique un
petit peu attention quand on va gagner
un match pas facile
de se dire qu'on va peut-être être
champion du monde d'échecs
nantes very very easy
prendre tout son temps chronique
kasparov qui fait la tête
fous ces 5
etc
tous ces sacs
et la casse par bluetooth et deux
prothèses champions et oui
kasparov protège champions il veut
lutter encore kasparov au la tête qui
fait la peau
kasparov
on croit pas que les blancs puisse
gagner cette finale mais kasparov la
joue à fond c'est probablement ces mêmes
certains c'est une finale que les noirs
peuvent tenir sans problème mais mais et
mine de rien mais pourquoi qu'elle soit
n'a pas joué comme ça depuis le début du
match c'est la question alors la tête de
kasparov n'est pas emballé une gamme
complètement écoeuré
c'est simple non il faut savoir que les
noirs peuvent même sacrifié le fou quoi
est-ce qu'il va jouer la finale touré
roi contrefous mais oui non on annule
très facile f6 f6 alors attention là
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya peut-être une
proposition non si de crâne nick wey
précis ce genre pas comment ils passent
la kasparov me fabre à oye autour h 2
oui parce qu'il ya gsm surtout ainsi si
la fée chronique la ola
est-ce que kramnik n'aurait pas fait une
gaffe
non non mais t'es sipa / faut penser 4c
fadoq et bientôt à six wi tourache 6 et
la foulée cinq échecs
oui et bien le roi et ficelles pour le
noroît juarez quatre mois je ne sais pas
des fous des caps n'ont à huy ah oui
tout simplement oui non c'est non non
non bref way
bref car fini c'est fini c'est bref
quatre que tu fais
bref quel jeu commence par te coller un
petit fou des six échecs et bien là je
joue et je te propose le roi de trois
mois je suis gentil je continue mes
petits et moyens je les aime bien la roi
eux deux près d'accord et qu'une
maintenant je reviens en défense et bien
logés 5
on est d'accord pas mal
c'était pas mieux ça va être nul droit
d'essayer sur les pick and go away 600
lei c'est archi nul alors voilà c'est
fini mais il attend on y mélange et 6
non c'est sûr on pourrait faire un essai
au port hier soir il faudra des fous
contrôle trop de cases bien devant m6
qui se passe sur 36 points f8 facile aux
fous des vides plutôt ouais c'est vrai
que les fous contre toutes les cases le
trop fort c'est très impressionnant
on va ramasser ses incroyables chronique
peut même pas militante du chronique
c'est ça qui est inquiétant et de 3,2 il
va jouer fou prend ses cartes et serge
chine-ue voilà voilà
la tête de kasparov et doit au regarde
olalala fait extraordinaire du tout
normal il a compris que c'était lui gary
kasparov s'est obligé quand il ya même
plus à combattre ça y est c'est fait fou
prend ses 4 g n'y a pas de bluff
il est souffrant ces quatre on va être
celle là c'est la fin c'est la fin
gary ne peut plus rien faire hop thouars
schisandra le 6 11 jouera et rigoletto
rage si cet ancien entourage 6 et après
fou des cinq séries de la rapide sans qu
on y est là on y est on y est stéphane
après fou des 5 est donc ravi qu à faire
des échecs
oui quand nick le faire des chèques qui
l'a propulsé droit de gary a eu deux
bras relate est garé tête de gary la
tête dugarry ouais c'est très facile
maintenant cramique le s'est garé le
celle ci leur kasparov là il a pas l'air
de vouloir gagner la juste de vouloir
jouer pour jouer
oui c'est soit ça s'est fini lassé d'un
instant à l'autre il en veut il en veut
pour son argent
kasparov sacre amis de jouer il ya 13
minutes pour jouer un coup ça va
aucun danger pour chroniques autant la
position pour 10 nuls de stéphane il
faut qu'ils jouent deux coups dans
treize minutes à vis de ce possible
non mais il va jouer sous des 5 voilà
c'est fait
attention au piège d'un instant à
l'autre attention ça peut être une ode
instant à l'autre
kasparov complètement dépité mais ça
depuis longtemps a fait don qu'il
bluffait pas il ne le fait pas car il ne
le fait pas la proposition est imminente
pour propose m bref 5 qu'est ce qui se
passe sur au fcn qui font un f3 pour
preuve six échecs ont relevé cette
baisse est important ah oui parce que je
vais prendre l'option avec un fou sans
problème sans aucun problème quand même
mokrani qui revient le lien est assis
maintenant j'y réfléchis mon petit gars
y est je te tiens je t'ai tenue assez
facilement une fois de plus gary fietz
portes à partir votre univers bref c'est
un brave scène quand même
il propose pas nul 1-1 de la journée et
tour il va jouer roi et tour contre eux
commencent à contrôler ses fans je
t'arrête au même s'il a l'air de vouloir
la jouer je t'arrête très bien mais il a
joui les joueurs comment ça non mais non
donc la chronique faits france ne
reviennent pas cette finale oui c'est
sûr qu'on a versé sur moi je la joue ce
que je sais pas la gagner je sais pas je
ne sais pas comment on obtient alors
c'est très simple rien à faire en fait
retenir s'il faut rien faire le si si on
se fait profession se fait pousser dans
3 mais il faut aller dans le coin opposé
de la couleur du fou voilà un bon tout
simplement
mais peut-être cramique le sait pas
c'est vrai peut-être que quand on dit
que le savez aussi alors qu'il avait
trois ans et qu'il n'a pas oublié sa
mémoire prodigieuse probable est-ce que
kramnik si annulé tour hiroire
contrefout en rivage ne faut point
francs c'est la question n'a évidemment
cui longs mais la question se pose pas
est un travail qui va se passer encore
au fond points 9-3 chronique des lieux
et hasbro fait une scène genre c'est moi
qui propose le oui ici ça avec les bras
comme ça là ouais y en a arbitre qu'on
parle d'une part ben voilà à et ouais il
faut prendre trois provinces éliminant
l'adulent il annule donc là n'en tenons
là un attentat temps parce que kasparov
a fait un roi proche des 5 créant non
j'essaie de gestion g58 dj 6 et loire
c'est l'idée ou aux chroniques le
rutilant cramé se joue le roi des cinq
la faute roi est loin des jouets déjà
dans trois ans mais maintenant il faut 3
we know me peine on m'attend c'était fin
je crois honnêtement que tous les coups
non mais j'ai si ces lois non mais c'est
pour ça qu'il faut jouer roi des 5 mai
g6 fou des cinq échecs la cobac alfred
il faut progresser il faut prendre les
six hommes trois des cinq c'est le bon
coup ici aucun doute est un des 5
attention pas faire de gaffe pas deux
gaffes pas de gaffe
et oui parce que c'est pas mal ce
efficace port il veut pas prendre le
pion aux six pour trois des cinq rondes
et 5 trop court entre annick very strong
ale canam nicolas nikki soc trang 41
coup voilà avons là ouais ouais ouais
voilà c'est le style phase iib for
chronic et bien une chronique se
rapproche du titre et loi ça je crois
qu'on peut le dire il est très proche
d'avoir gagné facile hein facile
tragique alors qu'on va avoir droit
la bande hors droits tout de suite après
à la conférence de presse des joueurs
dans 5 minutes qui sera suivi du résumé
en anglais présenté par danny king et du
résumé en français
voilà le programme qui vous attendent
direct et tous ces événements seront
disponibles dès demain en différé en
vidéo à partir de demain matin
et donc là moments importants kramnik
encore une fois a fait nul relativement
facilement avec les pièces noires et
kasparov n'a rien pu faire malgré un
avantage de deux pions
il semblait clair que les noirs ne
pouvait pas perdre cette partie kramnik
démontre une fois de plus qu'il est un
défenseur extraordinaire il sait tout
défendre il sait faire nul avec du
matériel à moins il est très fort ce
kramnik et il est en passe de devenir le
14e champion du monde d'échecs est
l'ancien champion du monde d'échecs
éventuellement seraient donc vladimir
kramnik tout cas c'est bien parti pour
pour une partie surprise
c'est encore cramique qui a dévié
le premier dans cette partie
il a réussi assez facilement un fair nul
on va avoir droit maintenant donc une
conférence de presse où sûrement qu'on
me mardi dernier et bien tu es sparrow
va être un peu des bides et c'est très
probable
on voit ici sur la scène larbitre
américain il ya trois arbitres pour ce
match c'est l'arbitré américain eric
giler on attend les joueurs
donc après la 11e partie kramnik même
toujours deux victoires à zéro
plus que cinq parties et kasparov n'a
plus que deux fois les pièces blanches
pour l'emporter
c'est quasiment foutu pour kasparov
ça serait un miracle d'autant plus qu'il
n'a pour l'instant gagné aucune partie
donc on voit pas comment il pourrait
remonter au score
kasparov
il a encore été une fois de plus surpris
par l'ouverture qu'a choisi kramnik qui
lui permet pas kasparov de sortir ses
préparations et la voyons effectivement
on voit kasparov qui est qui a l'air
complètement perdu
voilà les deux champions sont sur scène
et on va avoir droit maintenant aux
questions du journal
chronique quand même peu tendu
évidemment et kasparov qui est
complètement assommé kramnik à la peur
ou le stress de la gagne de gagner voilà
c'est parti
ok
fight night day